This video is brought to you by skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community with more than 22,000 courses right
now.
The first 500 people to click the link in the description can get two whole
months of skillshare for free.
Yeah.
It is one of the greatest nations in the world.
Germany is the linchpin of the European Union and the economic powerhouse that's
also homes,
one of the world's top creative capital's despite a history scarred by two world
wars and a 45 years of partition under a communist dictatorship.
It's a nation that's consistently been at the center of global affairs for 150
years and it only exists because of one man.
When all way von Bismarck was born,
Germany was a collection of 39 weeks.
States cowering between the superpowers of France,
Austria,
and Russia.
By the time he died,
the German nation had been forged in blood and iron and central Europe had a new
sheriff in town.
But while we all know the modern Germany,
he gave us a few of us know much about Bismarck himself.
In this video,
we take a look at the man known to history as the iron chancellor,
and just before we get into the main part of the video today,
I do want to say that there are a lot of Ziad German pronunciations.
If I screw them up,
I apologize.
Okay.
What else do von Bismarck was born in the Prussian village of Sean housing on
April the first 1815 it was into a wells that had been shattered by war,
not 10 years before Napoleon's grands.
Army had come storming through central Europe,
destroying the holy Roman Empire.
Ins leaving the Germanic states in ruins.
Bismarck's own home of pressure had been deeply humiliated by a French military
occupation,
not the young auto was aware of any of this.
Less than three months after he was born,
Napoleon was defeated at Waterloo for baby.
Also,
Napoleon's defeat meant being able to grow up on his parents' estate without
war.
I asked the right estate does why the image would lead to cultivate as a man of
the people.
I'll say von Bismarck came from the Prussian nobility.
His father was a young car,
kind of minor aristocrats.
While his mother came from a family of middle class professionals.
It's still money does not equal comfort.
Aged seven auto strict mother sent him away to school in the Prussian capital of
Berlin and experience.
There's also absolutely hated it.
He hated it so much in fact that the experience gave him a lifelong loading of
strong women like his mother.
While also he was siting in Berlin.
Europe was trying to rebuild itself after Napoleon,
the destruction of the thousand year old holy Roman empire had left a void in
the center of the consonants to fill it to the surviving.
So you have hours created something called the German Confederation,
a collection of 39 states locked in a loose association.
The confederation was designed to be weak.
It's power was balanced between the Catholic Austrian empire in the South and
the Protestant kingdom pressure where Otto von Bismarck was born in the north.
Now as we run through Bismark's life,
it's important to remember there was nothing at this stage that even remotely
resembled modern Germany.
When you hear us say Bismarck studied in Hanover,
it wasn't like you moving from say Colorado to Washington.
It was literally like moving to another country or be as one where they just
happened to speak the same language.
This language thing was why people started wondering why there were 39 Germanic
states and instead of one United Germany,
but that's something we're going to get to in a moment.
For now.
All you need to know is that also answered,
got again,
university and Hanover and the 1830s and he studied to be a lawyer remarkably
for such a great man.
He was useless as a student.
His friends considered him a dandy.
His tutors is considered him a drunk.
He scraped through his course and joins the Prussian civil service,
terminally boring occupation.
In fact,
it was so boring.
The Bismark wrote the pressure and civil servants is like one musician in an
orchestra.
He's confined to his own.
This part I however want to make my own music.
It's a quote Bismarck fans,
uh,
fond of because it points to his future greatness.
At the time though,
that future greatness,
it was very much in doubt.
This is mark actually quit the civil service in 1839 after his mother died and
he returned to his father's estate.
He briefly became a Bible thumping evangelical before marrying the pious you of
and put comma and living as just another Russian farmer.
The one notable thing that he did came in 1847 when he was sent to the Prussian
parliaments and made a number of speeches attacking the nation's Jews and this
stage in his early thirties he really was written more than a random hick from
Pomerania.
So you might know the saying come with the hour,
cometh the mat.
Well,
no one in 1847 Europe,
new as,
but the hour was very near the upon them and the man,
he was already there
in the library of European history.
1848 isn't the the giant red volume titled World.
On February the 20 seconds eight French government ban against banquets led to a
Paris uprising,
which depose the king belly three weeks later on march the 12th or similar
uprising and Vianna toppled Clemons.
Von,
Matt and Nick,
the guy who had been holding Europe together since Napoleon's defeat.
It was a spread of revolutionary it contagion of uprisings.
Often Matt and nick fell.
Nowhere was safe within days.
Berlin was paralyzed by riots,
which nearly brought down the conservative Prussian King Friedrich fill home the
fourth.
It was only by promising a slew of liberal reforms that Friedrich Wilhelm was
able to cling on to his power.
One of those reforms.
Well,
people could now discuss the possibility of uniting Germany.
For a guy who's famous for uniting Germany,
you might be surprised to hear Autobahn Bismarck wants it.
No pass of this nationalist revolution.
While liberals in pressure and other German states were holding elections and
creating a parliaments or write a new pan jam and constitution,
Bismarck was considering.
Arming,
has peasants and marching on Berlin zoo preserve Prussian sovereignty.
In the end,
the Bismarck settled for using his position in the pressure parliament to become
one of the loudest anti-revolutionary is in Europe.
The thing you've got to remember is that Germany had never really been a thing
before for Bismarck uniting all 39 states in the German Confederation meant
sending his beloved Protestant pressure into a support player in a nation
dominated by the Catholic Austrians.
On top of that,
the guys in are pushing to unite.
Germany were all middle class liberals.
Well,
Bismarck was a rate ultra conservative aristocracy.
He loved his king.
He loved goes and he loved to order for,
there's mark 1848 must have been a bit of a living hell,
but that's turbulent year.
It did provide Bismarck with one important boost.
It brought Bismarck firmly to Friedrich Ville home.
The fourths attention,
if they're on the revolution.
Bismarck was one of the most probe on men in Prussia.
Even when it seems the old order was amount to be swept away.
He claimed that stubbornly to the past like a reactionary Gemini limpets.
So when the forces of counter revolution,
finally our control in 1849 there's mark was perfectly placed to reap the
rewards as the revolutions failed in Prussia Australia Ahrens elsewhere,
thousands of gem and liberals were forced to flee to America.
By 1851 the old order had been completely restored.
If his services to the pressure and crown Bismarck was made ambassador to the
city.
State of frank fat's of old of the country's rocked by 1848 only one underwent
permanent change in France where it's a dual kicks off the old Monica.
His daughter was destroyed in its place.
A President Roosevelt,
who soon would become an emperor.
His name was Napoleon,
the third.
And if you've already seen a biographics video on him,
you'll know he and Lt von Bismarck wed destined to collide with enough force to
reshape the consonants.
On September the 30th 1862 a giant of a man slowly number to his feet and the
Prussian parliaments and he delivered a speech that would change European
history at six foot four and with a bodybuilder,
not unlike a particular type of brick outhouse.
Otto von Bismarck was a presence that always commanded attention,
but on this day it was his words rather than his size.
All volcanic temper that set everyone talking.
In the 11 years since 1851 Bismarck had been serving as Friedrich Ville.
Hamza ambassadors of the capitals of Europe had been in frank fet.
Some peaches SPEC had even briefly then stationed in the court of Napoleon,
the third in Paris,
and being so close to the levers of power had given him time to think slowly.
Bismarck could come to the realization that the world was changing whether he
liked it or not.
Men's dreams of a United Germany,
they hadn't died with 1848 and the Catholic Austrians were ascendant in the
German confederation,
even without a union.
Either the pressure drives,
stood,
bond watched.
The liberals and the Austrians dreams come true or he'd beat them at their own
game.
It was from these musings that Bismark's famous blood and iron speech sprang on
that day.
September the 30th 1862 Bismarck was in a precarious position roughly a year
before Friedrich Ville home.
The false a died and the Prussian crown had pasta is dull and to dimwitted son
Phil home the fast before 12 months past fell,
how accidentally spa to crisis that nearly toppled is governments.
The short version is that he need to tax rises,
that the liberal dominated Prussian parliaments simply wasn't willing to pass
with it looking like another revolution might be on the cards.
Wilhelm panics and recalls his father's old acolytes Bismarck from Paris to
become precious Minnesota presidents.
No one expected Bismark to last eight weeks and now Harry was announced to
deliver his first major speech to a hostile parliaments.
Nobody could have predicted what a bombshell it would be and is booming.
Germanic voice Bismark to clad the position of Prussia in Germany will not be
determined by its liberalism,
by its power.
He went on to say not three speeches and majority decisions will the great
questions of the day be decided that was the greatest mistake of 1848 and 1849
but by iron and blood for the first time.
Here we see Bismarck explicitly addressing the revolution of 1848 and not as
something horrific and to be forgotten,
but as something that was just done wrong.
Parliaments are trying,
talking and building a consensus and oldest had done was make chaos.
Now it was time to do it right.
It was time to unify Germany with iron and blood to be clearer on didn't just
mean war.
It meant rapid industrialization,
immense pressure that was building ships and bridges and railways so fast that
it could catch up with person and in France.
But yes it also did mean war.
Nobody in the parliaments new but Bismarck was about to embark on three great
was that would take Germany from 39 shattered states to a single BMF on
depression control.
So the neighbor was in parliament,
they on blood was the last thing they wanted to hear.
They tried to false veil home the faster remove his new minister president from
power,
even refusing to work with him when this marketing and collecting new taxes
without their approval.
Now that this bothered to Bismarck Pedro town to Prussia with a plan to forge
Germany and is conservative and Protestant image and the wheels forged from the
strongest on.
We're already in motion.
Okay,
so good news everybody whereabouts it gets into the war part of his life,
which I know you will love.
Well currently very popular on this channel,
but first skill shaft and so on.
Are you ready for a silky smooth transition because maybe in a test leadership
skills,
pretty important for all Bismarck and leadership skills as something you can
learn on skill shaft.
How about that presentation?
Essential is career development,
communication skills,
body language,
all on skill shot,
but it's not just the leadership skill set isn't online nine in community with
more than 22,000 courses.
Every time I make one of these ads it seems like the bands are like a thousand
new courses.
It's impressive.
They have clauses from design to business technology and much more so you know a
lot of online learning platforms.
They'd charge you by the course,
which can get pretty pricey after a while.
If you're like learning premium membership with skillshare though,
it lets you dive into any course you want so you can learn all of the leadership
skills you one so you know that other stuff I mentioned like technology or I
mean they've even got culinary skills,
languages this a lot to learn.
For me,
I've learned about video making on skillshare useful for what I do.
You can learn it.
Whatever you like.
Learning new skills is one of the most important things you can do to get ahead
and skillshare makes that super easy and super affordable.
Since skillshare is sponsoring this video,
the first 500 people to click the link in the description below,
you can get two whole months of skillshare for free and let's get on to that
war.
Shall We?
The British prime minister,
Lord Palmerston,
once remarked,
only three people I've ever really understood the Schloss vague Holstine
business,
the prince consort who is dead,
a German professor.
It was gone mad and I who have forgotten all about it.
All of this is just our way of saying that you don't need to worry about the
super complicated backgrounds or their second Schultz vague war.
All you need to know is that Schultz,
vague and Holstine,
where two regions on the border between the German Confederation and Denmark and
to this on February the first 1864 Bismarck convinced the Austrians do join him
in invading them.
The second release,
big war today is seen as the beginning of the German wars of unification.
More or less,
everything went according to Bismark's plan pressure and Austria,
Starbucks or Denmark occupied the peninsula and within months a taken control of
Charlottesville.
Holstine,
Holstine went to Austria.
I'll shawls speak when it's a pressure.
In the 21st century,
it's fashionable for historians to debates where the Bismarck really wasn't
genius,
so just extraordinarily lucky.
It's certainly true that the sac controls big war was possible only thanks to a
convenience succession crisis and shawls,
fake Holstine,
but Australia had no beef with stratospheric Holstine.
They didn't even want to innovate,
but Bismarck managed to convince Vienna that not joining his war.
We'd make pressure too powerful in the German confederation,
so join us Australia did and move that cost the most of their allies just as
Bismark wants it with Australia diplomatically isolated.
Bismarck then checked in on his old friend of mine,
a pony and the third to ask if Paris had any desire to protect the Ana when
Napoleon,
the third was all like,
ah,
that's cool dude.
There's mark said about engineering.
His second major war in January of 1866 Bismarck founds a pre taxed in Austria
is administration of Holstein.
Again,
the INS and outs,
they don't really matter.
What matters is the boundary in Austria and several German states including
Hanover,
ready for war with pressure.
This,
this was an exceptionally bad move.
The moment the starting gun fired on the seven weeks war pressures,
ultra modern,
ultra efficient army was bulldozing it's way across central Europe,
crushing everything in its path.
Seven weeks after the conflict exploded with the Austrian army,
the oscillator theaters back in Berlin Kaysville him,
he couldn't believe his luck.
He and his general staff could already envisage Prussian troops marching through
Vienna,
but that never happens.
Bismarck,
but is extremely heavy foot down.
That would be no march on Vianna,
no humiliating peace treaty for Austria.
All he wanted to do was forced Vienna.
It's a promise that they're never join a United Germany and if they agreed then
any future Germany would naturally be dominated,
not by the Catholic Habsburgs but by the Protestant oppressions.
This practically gave Ville home a stroke.
The Kaiser was so ASM and Australia be crushed that Bismarck had to threaten to
throw himself from a fourth floor window.
If Wilhelm gave the order to march on Vienna in the end of his marks,
the atrics they carried the day,
the Australians agreed to leave the whole uniting Germany.
Things of Prussia and Vienna was left standing back in Berlin.
The two wars that made Biznaga Herrick,
even the Liberals who've tried to get him fired today now sung his praises.
The court has got even allows out when Bismarck,
annex slice Vic and Holstine and Hanover and forced every Germanic states north
of the river.
Mine into is north German confederation by the ends of 1867 those 39 Germanic
states we started this video with had been reduced to just five in the south
though a Bavaria Bhajan voting bug and Hess,
Saddam Stotts,
and an auth Bismark's,
new Prussian dominated north German superstate straddled the Baltic Sea.
All that was needed now with some pretext to forgetting the southern states on
board with this new thing called Germany.
Luckily there's mark.
He had plans for one final war
for the most in Europe.
The creation of the north German confederation was greeted with enthusiasm for
liberals and German nationalists.
It was the moments that had been waiting for since 1848 and for the major
powers,
it was a useful corrective to the void left by the holy Roman Empire as
destruction.
But there was one man who was very displeased with the way things,
but going in Paris,
Napoleon the third,
he stewed in business,
having given Bismarck his blessing to go to war with Austria.
The French emperor had been expecting something in return and made moves to
annex Luxembourg for France,
but Bismarck stopped him worse.
He threatened to go to war over Luxembourg's neutrality.
Suddenly France was looking like the week European power against this booming
new nation of Germany.
So on a succession crisis blew up Spain in 1870 and pressure trying to step in.
Napoleon the third decided to assert his empire.
As you'll know,
if you watched our video on the polio and the thirds and trust us,
these do videos do really compliment each other wrong.
But well,
Paris dispatch,
the French ambassador to m's,
where he had calls today vacation in Kaiser Wilhelm the fest,
the two passions and arguments,
and then was that only,
it wasn't quite.
See Bismarck somehow got ahold of a memo about that arguments by now,
a master of the dark arts of politics.
See the editors,
what had been said.
So it appeared that French honor had been unforgivably insulted,
known as the EMS dispatch.
Bismark's edited memo did its job perfectly when Bismarck leaked it's contents
to the press.
The French public was so outraged that Napoleon the third declared war for the
previous three years,
but as mark had been trying to control the southern dramatic states since
joining his new confederation,
but without any success,
but with the French suddenly preparing to invade Prussia through those southern
states,
the holdout German real,
as they changed their tune,
terrifying of a dollar store.
Napoleon rampaging through their backyards,
Bavaria and the rest fled into Bismark's embrace.
Bismarck made it simple.
His army would protect them from the French on one condition.
They join his new Jimin Empire.
Once he had his agreements,
Bismarck set out to crush the French,
the French are gone toward expecting the other European powers to join them.
That Australia was now on good terms with pressure,
raven,
that whole not invading Vienna thing.
Well,
the Italians loved Prussia for giving Austria a kicking president and Russia
Ninewells simply didn't care about a squabble between Paris and Berlin.
So when the thread band wrench,
army,
finally a tag to the well-trained Prussian one on August the fourth 1870 it
wasn't even a route.
It was a massacre.
Over the next month,
the Prussians humiliated the French first day scattered their army,
then they invaded France.
Then they laid siege to Paris.
Finally on September the second 18 17th the Prussians surrounds it and capture
it.
Napoleon the third,
it was the death blow for the second friend Shantha.
It was also the bath of the German one.
On January the 18th 1871 Bismarck and Ville home traveled to Louis the 14th old
palace of Versailles to declare the creation of the German empire.
It was touch and go.
At the last moment,
Ville home decided he didn't want to be emperor but rather to be king and it was
only after another multi hour screaming match that there's Mark Convinced Ville
home that if you don't do this now,
Dum,
Dum.
Everything we've been working for him in the last decade will be lost.
Finally though,
the empire,
it was declared beneath a ceiling.
Fresco of Louis the 14th invading the holy Roman Empire.
French representatives surrendered the territory of Alsace Lorraine to Germany
and degree to pay an indemnity of 5 billion.
Frank's not 20 kilometers away.
Prussian bombs continued to fall on the citizens of Paris,
leaving them shell shocked and more ways than one.
Almost a quarter of a century after the liberal revolutionaries of 1848 says
fails to do so with speeches.
There's mark had finally created Germany with blood and with iron.
It was the dawning of a brave new world and Europe,
but it would never be the same again
if the 1860s what?
Bismark's decade of war,
the 1870s and eighties eighties whereas decades of peace with France scribbled
and Germany suddenly a thing the other powers sat at the table,
we'll started exchanging uneasy looks with one another.
I'm wondering if this new beer swilling nation was going to start something,
but they needn't have worried.
Unlike Kaiser Wilhelm,
the second or Hitler or Napoleon,
there's Marco is the conqueror who believed in restraint with Franco Prussian
war rover.
He halted and expansion.
He turned his attention to and tunnel security.
While future generations would assume Germany's existence with master of
destiny.
This is,
mark knew how fragile his new empire was.
Instead of fighting.
Now is the time for ruling as dual minister,
president of pressure and Chancellor of the new Germany.
This is mark rules with a strange combination of enlightenment and repression.
Only enlightened society introduced universal male suffrage,
the established a national healthcare system.
He introduced accidents,
insurance and it's brought in old age pensions.
This was Europe's very fast,
modern welfare states and it was complemented by enlightened acts on the world
stage.
In 1985 Bismarck house did a great power conference,
this and did the scramble for Africa,
you'll say,
devoted himself to European piece,
going out of his way to accommodate Russia,
England,
Austria,
Italy,
and even France.
But behinds this enlightened statesmen lay a guy who just couldn't stop himself
from occasionally acting like a petulant dictator in the early 1870s for
example,
Bismarck launched a policy known as cool to accomp dressed up as these things
usually are as a way of preserving a native culture.
It was really just an excuse to crack down on gem and Catholics and tries to
turn them into good Prussian style protestants.
This was followed in turn by a crackdown on Socialists and social democrats
since basically anyone to the left of Bismark,
which was basically everyone under 50 Bismarck was terrified of exiting and is
in revolution,
so he assumed cracking down on the forces he feared would keep him in office for
Rafa,
but while Bismarck was never overthrown,
he couldn't keep us enemies out of government either.
On the election of 1890 rolled around two decades of anti Catholic antisocial,
there's policies resulted in a landslide for the anti Bismarck forces.
However,
it was 1888 rather than 1890 this proved to be this on doing in German history.
1888 is known as the year of the three emperors.
That's because on March the ninth the fill home,
the first passed away and Frederick the thud became emperor.
Bismarck has known for years that Phil home was on the way out and it spends all
that time grooming Frederick just as a done Frederick's father.
Unfortunately for this marks well laid plans.
Frederick the third last just 99 days in office,
the followup dying himself in his way.
He can other man rose to the imperial throne,
a man who would go down in history for all the wrong reasons and that's
Kaysville home.
The seconds Ville homeless.
Second was everything.
Bismarck couldn't stand.
He was impulsive,
sulky,
prone to absurd decisions and most importantly utterly unwilling to listen to a
stuffy old winds bag who'd served his grandfather and great grandfather belly
had to drill home.
The seconds.
Backside warms the imperial throne.
Then he publicly dismissed Bismarck in 1890 the on John resigned to his oldest
date and a half expecting the governments do recall him the any moment,
but they never did.
All three lived eight more years.
Bismarck would never be in a position of power again
if Bismark's life had been the great raw of an iron ox is retirement was the
better thing of who we did bowl until his death is mock wrote books and
pamphlets and made long speeches.
Lionizing himself.
Well,
tarring Ville helm the sack and government has a bunch.
I think competent boobs,
well,
this well is doubtless chairing to his supporters.
It blades and unfortunate precedent Bismark's self mythologizing rent cemented
the image of Bismarck for blacksmith who single handedly forged Germany's
destiny.
It was an idea that hung around in German politics into the mid 20th century
influencing another self proclaimed man of destiny.
Adolf Hitler.
Unfortunate too was the way Bismarck simply Ranzit rather than taught in his
life.
It created a complex system of alliances and friendships to ensure no other
power tried to attack Germany,
but the system was so complex that no one else could really grasp it and so his
departure,
it's marked at the beginning of the slippery slope towards World War One.
Finally,
on July the 30th 1898 is mark passed away and his last moments,
he expressed regret that he hadn't been kind to his dog Selten before saying
that it soon z,
his wife Joanne,
or again,
he was 83 from our perspective,
it's impossible to overstate how important Bismarck was.
He managed to take a group of disparate European states and transform them into
a single United hole.
It's telling that even in the wake of World War One and world war two,
no one ever seriously considered breaking Germany up again.
Even the creation of communist East Germany ended with the two Germany's
reuniting in 1990 modern Germany,
maybe smaller than it was in Bismark's Day,
but its continued existence is now a geopolitical given.
Can we imagine a world without Bismarck?
Secondly,
it would look very different from all.
Well today Berlin would be a backwater.
The European Union likely wouldn't exist and Germany would just be a crazy dream
some way would liberals had ones that can 1848 on the other hand,
we'd have no world war one and World War Two,
no Hitler,
no Goebbels final solution.
Would it be a better world?
Well,
this fall removed.
What we could say is that it'd be unrecognizable.
Those who followed Bismarck may have used his creation for Eva Lens,
but there's no doubt.
The iron chancellor himself was a great man of history.
This is mock once said that he wanted to make his own music on the world's
stage,
even now,
over 120 years after his death was still singing from his hymn sheet.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos just like this several days a week.
Also,
please check out off on testing sponsors skill shep below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.